zurück bei Big live mit dieser Meldung
ein toter nach einem Polizeieinsatz und
wieder in Dortmund diese Nachricht
schreckt uns heute auf denn sie erinnert
an eine Tat an einen Vorfall aus dem
September tja da war ein erst 16 Jahre
alter seniger Leser auch in Dortmund
nach einem Polizeieinsatz gestorben auf
ihn hatte die Polizei zahlreiche Schüsse
abgegeben jetzt also wieder ein toter
nach einem
Polizei-Chef Reporter Frank Schneider
bei uns im Studio Frank was weißt du
über diesen Fall über diesen
Polizeieinsatz ja ganz wirklich viel
wissen wir noch nicht der Einsatz ist
sehr sehr frisch was wir aber sagen
können soll sich heute Nacht um einen
Einsatz gehandelt haben in die Polizei
über einen Notruf bekam dass ein Mann
randaliert er soll da vor den Häusern
das auch ein Kiosk der wohl noch offen
war soll auf Autos geschlagen haben und
als die Polizisten dann eintrafen
jedenfalls ist das so der erste
Polizeibericht sollte vom Tatort ja
genau soll der Mann auch sehr aggressiv
direkt auf die Polizeibeamten
losgegangen sein er soll auf das
Polizeiauto geschlagen haben und dann
haben die Polizisten jedenfalls ist das
stand jetzt Hazer eingesetzt den
Elektroschocker um diesen Mann eben
außer Gefecht zu setzen ein Tod infolge
dieses
tasereinsatzes kann man jetzt diesen
Polizeieinsatz schon in irgendeiner Form
bewerten aus deiner Sicht nein das kann
man noch nicht man muss natürlich eins
sagen ob der Taser im Endeffekt wirklich
die aus der Auslöser dafür war müssen
wir wirklich sehen wir sehen hier noch
mal so ein Taser im Bild da schlagen
zwei Pfeile in den Körper ein und dann
entsteht ein Stromfluss der kurz das
Nervensystem Leben soll und die
Muskulatur und den Täter außer Gefecht
setzen soll das Ding ist ja wirklich
angeschafft worden damit es eben nicht
zu tödlichen Folgen kommen leider muss
man aber sagen dass auch immer wieder
Einsätze gab wo Menschen verstorben sind
das hat aber auch damit zu tun wenn
Personen z.B unter Drogeneinfluss stehen
Alkoholeinfluss stehen ein hohen
Adrenalinspiegel haben auch
möglicherweise durch Stress kann dieser
Tesa das auch befördern dass du
Herzrhythmusstörungen kommt das kann zum
Beispiel auch sein dass jemand eine
herzvorerkrankung hat von der niemand
weiß und das dann zu Toten kommt das
wird jetzt hier erst eine Obduktion
wirklich klären auch da muss man
abwarten es kann auch sein dass sie erst
Obduktion gar nicht reicht sondern
sogenannte feingewebe ich Untersuchung
machen muss Drogen Alkohol und ähn über
den Band kann man auch noch nicht viel
sagen die Polizei sagt sie wissen
vermutlich wer es ist aber ist noch
nicht endgültigte identifiziert es
könnte sich um einen Mann aus der
Obdachlosen Szene handeln das muss man
jetzt im Einzelnen klären naja und jetzt
wird natürlich vor Ort alles
beschlagnahmen das wird alles an Spuren
gesichert und es wird jetzt ein ganz
klar natürlich ein rechtsstaatliches
Verfahren geht über die
Staatsanwaltschaft und eine fremde
Behörde ist in dem Fall die Polizei
Recklinghausen da werden jetzt die
Ermittler der Mordkommission den Fall
untersuchen die ja auch schon
beschäftigt ist eben mit dem anderen
Fall mit dem Tod des Senegal Lesen des
16-Jährigen in Dortmund du hast dein Ohr
näher an der Polizei als jeder andere
Reporter Frank sag uns einmal wie im
Moment die Stimmung dort in Dortmund ist
dort dieser auffüllende Fall im
September und jetzt der nächste tote
nach einem Polizeieinsatz ja es ist
natürlich für die Polizei auch ein
Albtraum dass das jetzt wieder passiert
und ausgerechnet wieder in der gleichen
Behörde hier ist natürlich der Fall
etwas anders gelagert es wurde keine
Schusswaffe eingesetzt aber hier wollte
man den Täter eigentlich außer Gefecht
setzen ohne wirklich schlimme Folgen und
der Mann ist tot ist noch reanimiert
worden vor Ort es war zwei Stunden
später im Krankenhaus verstorben und das
natürlich auch für die Polizeibehörde in
Albtraum und die wollen natürlich auch
rückhaltlos aufklären was ist da
wirklich passiert weil der Taser ist
natürlich auch in der neuen Koalition
schwarz grün jetzt in
Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht ganz
unumstritten bei den Grünen viele sagen
es ist ein super Einsatzmittel muss ich
vorstellen die Polizei das Pfefferspray
dann kam immer gleich die Schusswaffe
man wollte etwas einsetzen etwas
dazwischen haben was eben nicht zu so
schlimmen Folgen führt eine gute Idee
ist absolut und jetzt ist der Mann
trotzdem tot und das muss man natürlich
auch klar aufklären um auch zu gucken
ist der Taser dieses Einsatzmittel wann
kann man ihn einsetzen wann lieber nicht
denn die Beamten sind natürlich ein
Stück weit auch dem ausgeliefert sie
bekommen dieses Einsatzmittel setzen es
auch ein und am Ende ist der Mann tot
das wollen die Beamten ja auch nicht
sagt Frank Schneider danke schön für
deine ersten Informationen zu diesem
Fall
[Musik]